[Música]
en primera plana
carlos
[Música]
bienvenidos esto es en primera plana de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
alemania en cómo será la alemania post
merkel después de las elecciones que se
acaban de celebrar en el país para ello
me acompañan en este estudio luisa
corradini corresponsal en francia el
diario la nación que acaba de venir de
alemania de cubrir las elecciones
alemanas bienvenida luís enrique bonet
corresponsal del periódico de catalunya
y de la revista contexto bienvenido
enric buenos días gracias por habitación
y en dúplex desde berlín nuestro
corresponsal sergio correa sergio buenos
días buenos días a todos allá en francia
y bueno en el mundo que están escuchando
o viendo todo esto alcanzó en las última
noticia que tienen del nuevo gobierno
alemán después de 16 años de angela
knight en seguida no lo cuenta nuestro
corresponsal la alemania post merkel hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
[Música]
tras 16 años en el poder suceder a una
líder como angela merkel no va a ser
tarea fácil para quien la relieve
probablemente lo sea el socialdemócrata
olaf scholz hasta ahora vicecanciller y
ministro de finanzas en el propio
gobierno que dirigía a merkel si
consigue su deseada coalición tripartita
con verdes y liberales algo que se está
negociando estos días traen los
resultados de las elecciones alemanas en
las que la cuestión ecológica ha estado
muy presente hoy nos preguntamos qué
legado deja merkel y cómo será la
alemania post merkel la locomotora de
europa que como vemos de nuevo está
abocada a pactos de coaliciones para
llegar al poder repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja este asunto
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung tanto el
spd como la cdu reclaman la cancillería
ambos tienen opciones en principio le
corresponde le correspondería al
socialdemócrata jones el país olaf
scholz ofrece un tripartito a los verdes
y a los liberales y aquí en francia el
qb ganter nacional dedicaba esta semana
su portada a despedir a dios angela
merkel decía una mujer que ha cambiado
las maneras de ejercer el poder de eso
vamos a hablar también hoy bueno luis
acaba de regresar de cubrir las
elecciones en alemania luisa cómo vive
el país este cambio de este relevo tras
16 años de angela merkel
extraordinario porque los alemanes son
alemanes entonces hay una serenidad tan
extraordinaria el día de la votación el
día después cuando esos resultados ya
anunciaban que podría producirse una
revolución entre comillas en el país
bueno y la misma serenidad la misma
tranquilidad la misma
ah
la misma distensión alemania es un país
extraordinario en ese sentido para
nosotros los latinos y además hay una
una contradicción porque los alemanes
cuando les preguntas por qué hicieron
ganar a la socialdemocracia dicen por
qué o las jons es igual angela merkel
imagínense angela merkel que es de un
partido que pertenece a un partido
conservador que hace 16 años que
gobierna al país con su partido como
líder es una cosa fascinante esto o sea
que vamos iba a ser más fascinante los
resultados de estas negociaciones no sé
si en regular sorprendió los resultados
este triunfo de la socialdemocracia no
no si nos fijamos en los últimos sondeos
al final se han cumplido un poco los
pronósticos es cierto que a gran
sorpresa ha sido un poco la remontada no
de la socialdemocracia entre julio que
estaba 15 por ciento y que determinado
25 por ciento yo creo que una de las
claves de la victoria de las jons ha
sido sobre todo la debilidad de sus
principales rivales en primer lugar
armin las jet que tenía que suceder a
merkel no frente de los democristianos
de la cdu
que ha hecho una campaña pues bastante
catastrófica y sobre todo muy lastrada
primero por un proceso de selección de
le salió muy debilitado con muchas
luchas internas pero sobre todo y aún
más después con la gestión de las
inundaciones que hubo en julio y una
imagen que fue catastrófica para su
imagen no cuando se lo vio riendo a
carcajadas al mismo tiempo que el
presidente alemán está haciendo un
discurso muy solemne sobre estas
inundaciones y en segundo lugar también
la cantidad de los verdes que principió
a la campaña partido los verdes
comienzan la gran sorpresa incluso
esperada cancillería pero que se han
visto inmersos con muchas polémicas su
candidata atacada por su currículum al
final es la debilidad de la candidata de
los verdes y de harbín laietana han
facilitado finalmente la victoria de sol
en alemania desde 2005 tras las
elecciones del domingo pasado es el
momento de la negociación para ver quién
sucede a merkel todo apunta como estamos
comentando al socialdemócrata olaf
scholz sergio correa berlín al frente de
una coalición tripartita no
exactamente todas en esa dirección hacia
la otra posibilidad que es
matemáticamente realista que sería la
los democratacristianos edad derrumbado
completamente en estos días sobre todo
por la crítica de sus propios colegas de
los propios democratacristianos a la
gestión de su candidato que la chet que
aparentemente lo han renegado todo el
mundo y también la gente dice que el 70
por ciento de la alemanes no quieren a
la chet como canciller así que es
bastante improbable que él consiga un
lugar en este de gobierno llegara a ser
canciller
y parece además que se es olaf scholz
quien se ha beneficiado un poco del
legado de merkel más que el propio
candidato democristiano no
lo reivindicó muy inteligentemente en la
campaña por ejemplo había en todo berlín
había pancartas donde estaban su campaña
oficial donde él aparecía por un lado
diciendo yo puedo ser la canciller y por
el otro lado se hacía fotografiar con el
gesto tradicional de merkel con las
manos en rombo de manera que es
identifica auténticamente y es cierto
que tienen una excelente relación angela
merkel con el sol señalemos que ella se
apresuró a felicitarlo y a felicitarlo
por su triunfo cuando la chet
candidato democristiano esperó hasta el
miércoles para felicitarlo por los
resultados de la votación o sea que no
hay ninguna duda y la reacción de los
alemanes lo dicen scholz yo voté a
scholz
pero quiero señalar que hubo un millón
de votos de la democracia cristiana que
fueron a la socialdemocracia un millón
de votos esto significa que toda esa
gente que votó tradicionalmente
conservador decidió que olaf scholz
podía continuar con el
estilo y el trabajo de angela merkel
por cierto victoria del spd de la
socialdemocracia en tiempos en la que
los socialistas europeos hombre son
horas bajas para los socialistas
europeos puede estar visto que será un
revulsivo para la sección democracia en
europa enrico es de mucho decir yo creo
que es mucho decir es cierto que esa
pregunta que se plantea ahora también un
poco relacionada con la reciente
victoria de los socialdemócratas en
noruega nos hicieron que habrá en europa
en todos los países escandinavos noruega
finlandia suecia y dinamarca en gobierna
en la socialdemocracia también en la
península ibérica en el españa como en
portugal donde gobiernos socialistas y
esto ha hecho hablar un poco de un
cierto regreso de la socialdemocracia de
la cual se ha hablado
muchísimo de su gran crisis yo creo que
la crisis de la socialdemocracia
continúa y en el caso de alemania para
verlo bien hay que fijarse en el
resultado el spd ha sacado un 25
históricamente es un resultado muy bajo
para la spp en 2013 esa que me sacó este
mismo resultado 25 por ciento cuando fue
derrotado con contundencia por la cdu de
merkel por lo tanto yo creo que no hay
que sobre interpretar esta victoria lo
que pasa que los resultados el de la cdu
no el de los
resultados
yo yo estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con lo que con lo que está diciendo yo
creo que los alemanes no votaron o
votaron mucho menos a la
socialdemocracia que hola soy en
realidad esto ha sido realmente uno una
elección
personalista es el hombre al que el que
fue votado y no la socialdemocracia a lo
mejor me equivoco es una opinión y
respecto a esto yo creo que hay que
había una paradoja porque por un lado
jones ha verificado mucho de intentar
imitar un estilo un poco merkel ya no al
mismo tiempo es cierto que el hecho de
haberse posicionado bastante la
izquierda en determinadas cuestiones
sociales con alemania hay una
preocupación creciente no como con temas
como la vivienda que cierto que al spd
desde hace un par de años tiene
dirección bastante de izquierdas que
pretenden suponer souls que aún cándida
algún perfil muy centrista y ha habido
este este equilibrio
que al girar un poco a la izquierda los
últimos años y un candidato muy muy
moderado que ha terminado beneficiando
que al final venía a ser donde se le
pone intersección porque angela merkel
no viene a representar una cdu también
muy centrista es decir por eso por eso
ambos candidatos en cuenta se acaban
encontrando un giro de angela merkel en
este último mandato esto no hay ninguna
duda sobre todo con la pandemia eso es
interesante porque de ahí viene esa
sensación de que vamos a continuar con
el trabajo con el cambio el giro
y social de angela merkel en su último
mandato y loba con 100 soles le vamos a
preguntar a nuestro corresponsal por qué
tras 16 años en el poder la sombra de
merkel se proyectará sobre sus sucesores
casi seguro difícil tarea la de
reemplazarla sergio cuáles eran los
principales retos para su sucesor
si lo el clima es el número uno para
todos pero también de cierta forma es
fácil que están todos de acuerdo y el
problema está como se logra y cuánto se
está dispuesto a gastar o a poner de
impuestos el problema grave es
justamente el cambio climático exige
grabar mucho los combustibles y ahora
ese vio este año por ejemplo se triplicó
el costo el precio del gas la
electricidad pasar algo parecido
entonces eso es algo tiene que ver con
mucho cuidado y lo segundo mucho más
importante también por otro lado es la
digitalización algo que sea difícilmente
se cree en alemania pero claro alemania
un país industrializado uno de los
primeros exportadores del mundo tiene
una de las peores redes de internet de
europa el penúltimo lugar así que eso
tienen que hacerlo urgentemente ya
cambiar todos los cables y pasar de una
vez por todas a 521
qué curioso algún dato que nos aporta
nuestro corresponsal con un país como la
locomotora de europa pueda tener
problemas de este tipo no
solamente yo yo creo que a pesar de que
los alemanes hayan votado por la
continuidad entre comillas
va a haber un cambio fundamental
tiene que haber un cambio fundamental
alemania tiene que como dice nuestro
corresponsal tiene que cambiar en una
cantidad de cosas fundamentales la
ecología la política social hay un gran
problema con las con los sectores
populares por ejemplo esos famosos mini
jobs que son
trabajos con con tiempo limitado y con
un ingreso limitado creo que son 450
euros por mes a los que tienen que
recurrir la gente que no le alcanza la
jubilación y hay miles y miles y miles
de alemanes que tienen pequeñas
jubilaciones y que no llegan a fin de
mes o sea que realmente la política
social tiene que cambiar sin hablar de
los cambios que se van a producir con
respecto a la política europea porque
obviamente si hay una coalición que no
tiene nada que ver con el gobierno
saliente en los cambios se van a
producir o sea que va a ser fascinante
sobre todo los cambios que vienen de la
cuestión climática porque lo vimos en
los debates que la cuestión climática
estaba en el centro de los tres debates
que se celebraron en acto ha sido una de
las cuestiones centrales bueno
básicamente debido al hecho de la crisis
climática estará a la vuelta de la
esquina para producir más cerca pero
parece que en otros países como francia
cuesta más posicionaron el centro de la
cuestión
los alemanes
en el cambio climático yo creo que
estará muestra mi presión de las
próximas presidenciales en francia y en
alemania es cierto que el cambio
climático también estará relacionado
ahora a la complejidad de estas futuras
negociaciones ya que en principio los
actores claves que han sido los primeros
en reunirse los verdes y los liberales
defienden en parte de posiciones
contrarias porque un lado de los verdes
son partidarios y
creen en la necesidad de que la
administración pública tiene que
invertir para impulsar esta
transformación verde en cambio los
liberales básicamente sus postulados son
reducir impuestos y son muy reacios al
gasto y también tanto en alemania y
también a gasto en europa como he visto
recientemente en el plan de
reconstrucción no el año pasado en parte
donde el hecho de mutualizar la deuda
parte también está relacionado con la
ambición de impulsar una transición
verde para ver cómo consiguen conjugarse
para hacer esa coalición llamada
semáforo entre el spd los verdes y los
liberales en unos instantes continuamos
hablando de ello pero hacemos una breve
pausa en este punto hasta ahora
e
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 cada
semana santiago lópez recibe en su mesa
a personalidades para debatir un tema de
actualidad lo que es necesario en esos
momentos es una respuesta es tratado
políticos especialistas periodistas
artistas o activistas se reúnen durante
casi una hora para exponer sus puntos de
vista en eeuu y creo que cambio
plenamente el concepto de las relaciones
internacionales todos los temas están
permitidos pero yo no voy a responder a
insultos y descalificaciones
participé en el debate a través de las
redes sociales con el hashtag el debate
es de 24 acompañarme en el debate por
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
france24 en español pasa 24 horas de
difusión diaria 24 horas para informarse
de toda la actualidad de américa latina
y el mundo todos los días desde el
terreno a través de nuestros noticieros
y programas hablamos con los dirigentes
del continente y también de los que
hacen la actualidad política y económica
artística y cultural para ofrecerles una
información incompleta del mundo que
confronta a todos los puntos de vista
nuestras redacciones en américa latina y
en francia trabajan en estrecha
colaboración para estar siempre presente
en todos los eventos importantes y
proponerles una mirada diferente
france24 en español ahora
liberté égalité actual y d
hola bienvenidos a revista digital una
inmersión en profundidad en lo bueno lo
malo y lo feo del mundo digital un
reportaje de la televisión francesa
dedicado a denunciar locos a cenas
clandestinas en parís desde la
democratización de la información a
través de las redes sociales hasta la
masificación de las técnicos obtener una
línea telefónica en méxico ahora
requerirá que usted proporcione hasta
sus datos biométricos
[Música]
acompáñame en la crónica de revista
digital por france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
esta semana hablando de alemania de cómo
va a ser la alemania post merkel lo
hacemos con los periodistas luisa
corradini enric bonet y desde berlín
nuestro corresponsal
sergio correa antes de irnos a la pausa
estábamos hablando con el rhic de cómo
se van a ajustar esas piezas para la
llamada coalición semáforo luisa la de
coalición entre el spd y los liberales y
los verdes estaba pensando en el
semáforo o semáforo por los colores con
los colores con los que se identifica
claro ahí se necesita un ajuste de
piezas un ajuste de piezas un ajuste
programático los alemanes tardan en
llegar esas coaliciones lo vimos con las
grandes coaliciones de merkel con el spd
y una vez que llegan lo cumplen punto
por punto unos programas que son
enormemente complejos pero que al final
del mandato se gana se gana términos que
para nuestros oyentes sobre todo
latinoamericanos que no están
acostumbrados de este tipo de forma de
gobierno esto podría ser prácticamente
milagroso imagínense ustedes gobernar a
tres
con
programas completamente diferentes con
intereses completamente diferentes es
cierto que hay que ser alemán
para poder gobernar así efectivamente
esto es el ejemplo de los cuatro
mandatos de angela merkel angela merkel
gobernó 16 años
los conservadores con los
socialdemócratas pudieron conseguirlo
incluso hubo otros y otras alianzas y
siempre siempre se cumplió programa como
bien dices tú
sí que serán negociaciones largas
complejas no como ya sucedió en 2017
donde estuvieron seis meses y que en
parte se alargaron mucho también no
porque al principio merkel intentado ser
una coalición con los liberales y los
verdes para intentar hacer ahora opina
el socialdemócrata souls o él o los
democristianos y en ese caso se mostró
una cierta incompatibilidad los verdes y
los liberales o sea esto nos muestra yo
creo que van a ser negociaciones
bastante complejas pero es cierto que en
alemania es una atención más positiva
que en general cuando hay un acuerdo de
gobierno final es que se termina
pactando y es un país donde hay una el
parlamento de la política está muy
fragmentada como está pasando en el
resto de europa en parte yo creo
vinculado a la crisis de representación
que es muy importante grupos de hace una
década pero a pesar de esa fragmentación
político en general hay una cierta
estabilidad a partir del momento que hay
una coalición se termina llegando hasta
el final del mandato
con respecto a la coalición hablemos
ahora respecto a la persona al respecto
al nuevo canciller porque claro tras 16
años de una figura que va a pasar a la
historia como es la de langella la de
angela merkel es imposible que su
impronta que su sombra que no haya
comparaciones del día de mañana con el
que va a ser su sucesor porque su
impronta va a ser muy alargada a la de
angela merkel una duda angela merkel la
figura de angela merkel va a seguir
planeando sobre la política alemana
durante mucho tiempo nosotros todos los
periodistas hemos dicho cuando siempre
para dejar el poder y entrar en la
historia
angela merkel va a entrar en la historia
no solamente de alemania por supuesto
sino del mundo porque ha sido la mujer
más poderosa del mundo considerada la
mujer más poderosa del mundo durante más
de 15 años o sea que pero esto no quiere
decir que angela merkel tenga la
intención de seguir incidiendo o
participando en la política alemana le
voy a preguntar por ello a nuestro
corresponsal en berlín porque es verdad
como dice luisa sergio que dicen quienes
la conocen que merkel no interferirá en
la labor de su sucesor que su falta de
vanidad le facilita retirarse del poder
forma digamos sana aquí se va a dedicar
hasta ahora canciller a partir de ahora
cómo será su vida tras 16 años en el
poder bueno le han preguntado muchas
veces eso yo sé que antes conocí amigo
que la conoce tenía la idea de hacer un
libro de cocina lejana si le gusta mucho
cocinar y que no lo podía hacer casi
nunca ahora pero además sí bueno ella
aparentemente man quiere ocupar ningún
cargo hay mucha crítica sobre la
ocupación de excancilleres ya pasaron
dos que pasaron a la industria privada y
eso fue una cosa bastante escandalosa
ver que probablemente bueno va a quedar
igual con una oficina dentro del
parlamento con dos asistentes con un
chófer con un auto oficial con
secretario así va a tener una si quiere
dedicarse a hacer algo con respecto a la
organización política interna del país
va a tener muchas posibilidades pero
hasta ahora yo no ha dicho nada
solamente y quiere dormir mucho que
quiere dormir mucho
[Música]
que se retira por voluntad propia que no
se retira porque fue derrotada eso
fundamental como como lo ven radica en
la figura de merkel dejando el poder una
figura que interfiera poco sobre su
sucesor si yo creo que tiene pinta que
va a interferir poco de hecho
en los últimos últimos meses y años se
han involucrado bastante poco en su
proceso de suspensión primero eligió una
del final para que fue ministra de
defensa a negrete en bouwer pero para él
no le salió demasiado bien y luego se
aparta un poco que ahora sea un poco ese
también se le ha reprochado en el
fracaso de la siedo de que se hubieran
finalmente involucrado poco en su
sucesión yo creo que sí que es bastante
probable que se va a apartar va a tomar
ciertas distancias y bueno y veremos qué
va a pasar si va a emerger una nueva
figura importante en alemania o no yo
creo que la quita es la ventaja que
puede tener el futuro canciller es que
ahora alemania llegamos un momento
después de esta crisis tan importante
con la pandemia del cómic 19 que es un
momento casi de ruptura bueno de cambio
no del nuevo canciller tendrá que asumir
los grandes desafíos no del siglo 21
como hemos dicho la el cambio climático
la digitalización también en principio a
nivel económico aunque es probable que
haya bastante continuidad las mismas
recetas que se aplicaron a principios de
los años 2000 ahora ya han quedado
bastante que no se pueden volver a
aplicar entonces estamos en épocas
distintas yo creo que la suerte o la
oportunidad que puede tener el sucesor
de merkel para no para ante esta sombra
que le puede hacer la canciller es que
estamos en épocas distintas y ahora hay
desafíos distintos por cierto que al
igual que existe cuando hablamos de que
se va a retirar sin interferir en el lo
que haga su sucesor al igual que existe
el alcoholismo el sarkozysmo el
traumatismo es muy raro hablar del
merkel ismo no vamos a escuchar el
merkel ismo es como si existe una falta
de vanidad absoluta en su figura
no dejará rastro en el futuro a
diferencia de otros que se han ido yo no
estoy tan segura yo creo que la gran
capacidad de angela merkel como
dirigente a nivel nacional era que ella
es capaz es pragmática es capaz de
cambiar de opinión si ella entiende que
eso es en beneficio de su país y eso es
el merkel ismo y yo no estoy segura de
que
de que mucha gente sea capaz de hacer
este tipo de cosas o sea que como bien
decías
si alemania tiene que cambiar y tiene
que ir hacia adelante
va a tener que superar el merkel ismo
porque el mecanismo
identifica una forma de gobierno es una
forma de gobernar en la que tampoco se
pueden tener muchas visiones a largo
plazo porque eso estrecha mucho no es
llegar a compromisos con otras fuerzas
políticas
cuando se gobiernan con una coalición
eso es fundamental y eso es lo que mucha
gente mirando desde el exterior olvidó
siempre cuando criticó la acción de
merkel ella gobernaba en una coalición
con un parlamento que tiene una extrema
importancia en alemania y un parlamento
donde está la extrema derecha y ante
todo una obsesión que ha tenido siempre
la cantidad de la merkel es mantener a
raya esa extrema derecha de alternativa
por alemania un ejemplo para formaciones
conservadoras quizás de otros lugares de
europa como ha mantenido siempre angela
merkel está absolutamente fíjense cuando
angela merkel tuvo el coraje de ir en
contra digamos de la opinión pública y
abrir las puertas a más de un millón de
inmigrantes
fue cuando le abrió también las puertas
de la extrema derecha en extrema derecha
entró en el parlamento un tiempo después
por culpa de ese problema de integración
que había había creado esa cantidad
gigantesca de
inmigrantes digamos algo ya ahora cinco
casi seis años después de ese gesto
fabuloso de angela merkel
la aventura se puede decir que tuvo un
éxito absoluto la gente está
prácticamente integrada ese millón por
supuesto siguen habiendo problemas pero
siguen habiendo problemas porque es
mucha gente para integrar pero la verdad
es que es un ejemplo para el resto de
europa que sigue poniendo barreras y
sigue poniendo excusas y buscando
excusas para no aceptar un puñado de
inmigrantes en cada una de las partes de
su legado lo más recordado cuando acoge
a un millón de refugiados si fue fue un
gesto muy importante que en parte
también les sirvió para compensar otro
momento donde su imagen era muy
cuestionada europa en relación con la
crisis del euro de la crisis en grecia
que estoy pienso que la parte más más
oscura de su balance no luego es verdad
que lo de los refugiados fue un buen
gesto aunque es cierto que si lo miramos
en perspectiva la final a las políticas
que ha terminado aplicando europa han
terminado pesando más las de ciertas
reticencias y de oposición a la acogida
de refugiados porque no hay que
olvidarnos que en pocos meses después de
ese buen gesto de en marzo de 2016 fue
cuando se firmó el acuerdo con turquía
para controlar la llegada de refugiados
sirios a través de turquía y para
reforzar las fronteras europeas en
turquía y esta externalización de
fronteras que luego se ha extendido por
una parte de las fronteras del viejo
continente no en definitiva un buen
gesto un gesto simbólico importante pero
al final la presión de otros países y
también yo creo la presión interna en
alemania han terminado pensando que la
política europea a nivel de acogida de
refugiados ha sido razón de reticente y
de y de oponerse a ello pero tras 16
años también se ven en matices por
ejemplo en la crisis del euro sí que
veíamos una visión mucho más austera
para ahora mismo con el coronavirus y la
mutualización de la deuda es hecho
posible porque alemania ha cambiado esa
posición en los avales y a eso me
refería cuando me refería el giro social
de angela merkel en realidad de hecho
creo que por eso yo insisto siempre en
que angela merkel gobierno en función de
las necesidades o de lo que le pedía su
país
y en el último mandato parece haber
dicho bueno ahora voy a hacer algunas
opciones que son importantes para mí por
eso ese cambio de angela merkel yo
siempre la sospecha de ser mucho más
social y estar mucho más
a pesar de que no es una personalidad de
izquierda que de estar mucho más a la
centroizquierda de lo que en realidad
estuvo en sufrir la mayoría de sus
biógrafos dicen que podría haber llegado
al poder por los democristianos pero
podría haberlo hecho perfectamente por
el partido socialista la amenaza de la
extrema derecha de alternativa por
alemania parece que ha ido disminuyendo
sobre todo por ese cordón sanitario que
parece tan ferro en alemania del resto
de los partidos sergio corresponsable el
discurso de merkel debe de merkel debe
irse ya ya no les vale y por eso no sé
si perdieron fuelle aunque todavía niega
el 10%
ellos probablemente bueno bajaron un 20%
no es no es poco pero igual siguen
siendo un jefe de estado en dos estados
federales y tienen cierta clientela
programa se ha mantenido no han caído no
ha sido una fiebre por ejemplo no han
conseguido renovar sus cuadros todavía
sigue siendo un cuadro del estilo matón
creo que quien no va a subir solamente
esto dependería si tienen un problema
con la economía pero como le comía anda
bien entonces esa parte de la extrema
derecha no progresa tanto como se podría
hacer la demo
claro que la extrema derecha y también
la extrema izquierda también delinque
donde tienen fortalezas en el este
alemán en el oeste son formaciones que
sacan muy poco muy pocos resultados
bueno por último os quiero preguntar
creen que va a haber gobierno alemán
antes de navidades
esa es la pregunta del millón debería
debería todos expresan su voluntad de
llegar aa
en navidades con un gobierno pero la
verdad
sí yo creo como la compañera debería
verlo pero no no tengo una bola de
cristal entonces es difícil saberlo y yo
creo que debería haberlo también sobre
todo a nivel europeo porque si no lo hay
antes de navidades es probable que nos
vayamos a un periodo de bastante
parálisis europea porque vamos a
encadenar este momento de vacío de poder
en alemania y luego a las elecciones en
francia es un año sin líderes y en
francia de alemania sería grave para
europa efectivamente en muchísimas
gracias a los tres es un placer
compartir este tiempo de primera plana
con todos ustedes y ahí les espero la
próxima semana quien en primera plana
muchas gracias
[Música]